you
dozen seconds left 30 small crew maybe
more will enter alrighty we have the
Philips tournament he created tournament
who a late joiner I guess mac-and-cheese
won all right let's go at the Bishop b5
oh really
Queen b6 okay
Oh guess I'll take and let's try to make
use of my lead in development let's kick
him around
I think d6 was better before that night
move very tempted to just play Knight d5
but don't know about that 94 in to d6
even if Bishop b4 I'll go 94 take my
rook I go here that doesn't seem right
there's some serious holes that I could
create here d6 is already a hole f6
maybe let's jump in and I'm gonna wreck
there dark squares soon let's go
straight in for it and I don't know here
in to g6 drop the d6 pawn but I don't
know it's got to be something in these
dark squares like well I could just get
another piece involved first pawn push I
could take this Knight is a beast and a
half let's take him out we can here
threatens me I'll take the bishop if it
goes here okay let's go over here give a
check take another pawn because this
guy's pinned
bishop here is possible yeah it is don't
want to get made it on g2 my my night is
really killing their queen discover
check stuff happening
that's a check and I guess I guess just
here
and really anything at this point I'm on
the rook well and their Queen but they
were really long time at that point
generated a lot of threats ooh hoo sea
shark and a half in here hamadan I
haven't played him in a while and the
chess Prince still have flashbacks from
playing the from taking a few beatings
against the chests prince in that one
three check tournament am I the only one
that recalls that maybe those are
painful defeats I loved three check all
right we're gonna go immediately wits d5
and not allow the Queen Knight to even
step foot on c6
so we're doing a little night dance
that's a it's fine with me the trade
that just came about my bad Bishop for
their good Bishop exchange in other
words let's just keep him out of here
altogether a week in my light squares
but maybe I'm alright with that um
actually I should maybe played f3 let's
continue to strike on the Queen side I
want to make sure I maintain control
over e4 I don't know if I'm really doing
such a good job of that probably get my
rook here it's an open file and it runs
out of a knight f6 pawn push ideas I get
into this hole if they play you for I
don't know I'm prepared to double on the
B file I got to keep the knight out of
these two Queen is here to offset their
queen let's just go here and welcome in
exchange rule out any possibilities for
a sacrifice on g3 and I could also
reposition here this is maybe a threat
let's jump right in maybe not best
looking to enter on the seventh they're
down on time and resulting a bishop I
could jump right in bishops
we're looking pretty good here um well I
could just take that rook that's good
they're down on time though all right
back to tournament where do we stand
here someone Christoffel has eight that
was pretty quick wins killer cows is up
there with five berserk xx as round
three I am in sixth have efore on board
I have to get it out of my system just a
little bit my fishing pole let's see
well let's start with this can't I can't
resist
alright this nights gonna jump in here
one day well let me get the dark square
bishop or they have to take my knight
I'm threatening made on each - what are
they gonna do there they're gonna think
tank I've seen players before spend
spend a lot of time thinking there and
still miss the h2 threat they kind of
get ahead of themselves let's just break
this pin there's some pretty serious
weaknesses going on here let's point at
their King let's go here I can't castle
um I really don't want to take my rook
off of the h-file I missing something
juicy here let's go with this get a
passed pawn open up this diagonal I
don't know I want to tuck my King in
here I don't want to pull my rock out
for that let's box the net out this is a
connected past pawn now alright so maybe
you get off of that file sneak over here
into h3 or maybe target e4 that's
actually pretty difficult to defend and
there goes the Queen she's gone see
that's one of the drawbacks when you
defend against
now the h2 threat you're playing g3 to
blunt that dog and all the c7 h2
diagonal a weakens the light squares so
immediately the Queen Bishop queen
bishops eyes light up and if I am not
mistaken I saw Ferrari in there so
better kick it into a higher gear cuz
you could be sure he's gonna mow down a
lot of the competition
should I have allowed that I don't know
I'm gonna need some breathing space
somewhere else
ooh actually that's just a free piece so
forget about needing breathing space I'm
up a piece now let's open up the Queen
side here in-betweener why not alright
this position is officially opened up
I'm up I'm definitely open with the
Queen exchange and I'm up another piece
and they resigned back to tournament
land 12 is where we stand in who's right
on my heels berserk town three games in
a row
Ferrari third is AMA Don so clearly some
late joiners here there were about what
30 at the start 15 more entered and many
super strong okay let's see what we got
here
a bishop deploying to d3 looking to tuck
himself away there so a royal apes'
let's get this in week in this square
but I have some minor pieces that could
watch over it and then let's go here
first start um I'm winning upon though
yeah I have many attackers let's go here
actually I'm on the Queen and the bishop
Queen g5 seems interesting but is it
good seems interesting but is it good I
know that that is exactly what you were
all thinking
okay there's a whole jump in there you
look at pins we can also take a free
rook
and another free piece here I'm gonna
get my knight actually I'm up of rook
that's a pin take care um spending too
much time 22 seconds I'm making this far
more complicated and is necessary um
this is ridiculous what I'm doing I just
drew a blank there okay here and then I
just want to get coordinated basically
oh I just dropped my rook they're gonna
see it I'm up a rock and struggling not
a good sign if you're up a rook and
struggling hey you got all the checks
covered there you go
just keep moving to squares where your
pieces are defended I am really
struggling can he do it can he do it
three seconds and now I have to go in
for a Queen trade and that this was the
only way to win only way to win
fantastic technique everybody should try
this kind of technique next next time
you play on a convert a rook advantage
clean yeah 20 minutes left
16 I have one point lead but yeah you
could be sure if I stay up there I'll be
paired with the Ferrari
alright let's push through we're looking
for a six soon um okay guess we take the
Queenie
now they're on my bishop at the end I
realized that this is okay though
because this is a nice home that's a
hole and there he goes and there he will
stay for the rest of the game really
can't really challenge that guy I keep
my rook here I want to keep one rook on
board that was probably a mouse slip or
maybe not no they wanted to be able to
move their night huh in-betweener
that's costing a piece all right these
are all holes on the e-file let's just
go here I don't find what to trade let's
see if I can convert this one being a
knight up it's really not a good sign
that I'm struggling
to win win games where I'm up a piece of
keeping let's keep that night I want to
just improve my king position there we
go
now we got this guy next I run I want to
rule out all their pawn moves their king
is getting flushed back little by little
all right he's going down next got him
let's maintain my king position watch
out for sneaky pawn moves all right
there King I shouldn't have allowed that
pawn to move no stalemates 15 seconds
plenty of time and here we go forget
forget about you even have the night I
was almost ready to play King here
okay back to Turner there we go Ferrari
is tied
he's preserved all but one game 2020 is
this game over with we might be getting
paired up right now um Hamadan took a
hit maybe he was paired up with Ferrari
who knows okay here we go what do we
throw at this guy hmm got 20 seconds and
make the first move we're gonna go with
d4 okay speediness
you got this he moved I didn't see it he
moved and I didn't see it
uh he does those he lines up sacrifices
with Queens CA he's done that before
sneaky guy oh that works doesn't it but
I want to have something I feel like I
should have something here oh they're
giving me the exchange back
oh they do that on purpose I kind of
want to see that taken I want the d5
square I want to kick the night out and
then get into d5 what's tempo I like my
position I have a couple ponds I take
here and I'm on the Queen okay I could
still take and go here as an
in-betweener oh not here I have to take
mmm he's sneaky sneaky guy now we could
go here with the Queen pick up the rook
if the knight moves liking my position
and the clock
the bishop really isn't contributing
actually the bishop could have played
here threatening mate you have to worry
about that I could pick up the rook with
check here here and then take wits check
um hang on here for a second
now we're going to push because I could
take what's check
all right now we're going here next
probably no matter what I got this
do we I got the Queen that should do it
and here we go all right they resigned
back to turn I would have been a little
scared I think they might have mouse
slipped Bishop e7 because they had that
clean on g3 and lining up a battery
against h2 that would have made me sweat
definitely would have made me sweat a
little bit
all right people dough give him a flat
tire but he's he's in you could be sure
he's in the pit stop right now
he's not going to go into the night
quietly is basically what I'm saying
now all righty where do you go from here
I guess we play with the bishops and
give them a pond all right we're gonna
relocate my bishop on this diagonal
because what else is there okay maybe we
could even pick up the beep on yeah
we'll go pawn hunting hopefully my queen
doesn't get trapped oh oh just as I say
that huh I got it I got to disrupt the
Queen okay I think she'll be rescued she
could get into Seaside my Knights
defended okay
we're out we escaped queen don't be
afraid we're on the rook good
coordination my bishop is fantastic
they're looking to disrupt him not much
I could do there were two different
squares I could have gone to my knight
is good there Knight is boxed out I'm
fine with some trades let's go here my
king will be responsible for watching
over these squares I guess we have to
babysit upon not fun get over here
make a nothing move making I'm not sure
what that move is doing move he and I
could go here where are the forks where
are they dark squares there they are
no there's a better move man I could go
here kick the Klingon away now we're
cooking with check here was better this
is the new seventh rank
back here here we go there dad
on time true 29 28 24 amadon is up there
versus some berserkers he's on fire he's
paired up playing against John oh we got
the Ferrari again we have a carro con on
board I don't know let's see this so
much let's just decline that
Oh back up here we go okay I'll take
know you were gonna force me into it
maybe I could have delayed for one more
move what's some pressure
I'll go Queen side that's a pretty scary
Bishop let's offset him not gonna help I
don't know that's a nothing move that's
just a nothing move
I mean trade wouldn't mind seeing a
queen trade can I force it a little uh
oh that was a bad move Teddy just pinned
I'm playing hope chess here why am i
what am I trying to challenge the speed
of this guy all right let's take one
night out
okay I'm poking around some now we have
some weaknesses let's hang out of my
pond they're looking to go in here I
could probably get forked here soon even
on the clock
I've weakened my King some let's I don't
know what I want to do a good sign
yeah oh there's night forex I'd better
get out of that
oh boy I could take their and they're
going in with the fork oh I'm so busted
oh I got a drum down that's mate ah man
I floundered for too many moves I played
scared
I played scared what should I have done
there I needed to go with the pawn break
but I didn't mmm okay I am three back
from the top this guy is berserk me
maybe I should have bridge irked him
back
yeah I liked the opening result but I
just didn't follow through with any
middle gameplan what can I say so you
can't really expect much can you when
you play like that all right we're gonna
try to just might be a quick one I don't
know here get the bishop involved
Mary come on man where's the mate
where's the mate here we go um here
struggling to find a mate oh can he do
it yep another one of those this is the
only way to do it
yep you couldn't made him on the
queenside he was impossible to make them
on the queenside force them over to the
Kings side cuz that's the only spot you
could give checkmate 950 134 is top I'm
at 30 fireless Ferraris at 29 all right
I have to definitely win out I don't
think you can afford two losses one
maybe in this field too you're probably
in forget about it land and if I take
that to take with the Queen I like how
my mouse is doing so he's playing a good
game all right they they could play
Knight b5 I play Bishop here yeah let's
throw a punch that's an awkward way to
defend that weakens c3 I guess here and
then c7 another bishop still they take I
have mate and I'm threatening the bishop
how cool would that be
let's get Bishop here long diagonal
gonna take me
probably exchange dark square bishop
before I get hurt threatening maid again
can't block this time I could have taken
the bishop oh but we have made on each -
there we go thirties oh my goodness that
was a fast paring let me celebrate a
little bit
keeping made on my favorite square that
was that was the fastest paring in this
tournament
man someone what's how many seconds less
than a second and you're paired right
away give me some time to breathe hmm
all right let's hunt down the dark
square bishop or develop with tempo
maybe we win the Queen and we do know
they have to pitch upon a five was one
of the few squares remaining for the
Queen II don't know if I took the right
way we're still looking to hunt down the
Queen and she's got a runaway
I got discovery soon I don't have a good
discovery with my bishop how about we
throw a knight in to d6 have the F file
now oh that's a free night you could
take free nights I didn't see it
thankfully they didn't see it let's go
here I want to move the bishop and
actually keep Queens on the board
really
there we go maybe we got the rook Queen
b6 I guess trade one no let's do this
they can't take I could just take my
knight I'm missing a lot of stuff
fortunately they're down on time
fortunately this was not good I had
something let's just get a flight square
make sure you don't lose
yeah here we go I don't know anything
time and I don't have technique in this
game alright anything come on man
anything doctor tournament 3730 ooh oh
man
okay one point back let's try this okay
let's see how we do in this advanced
French structure I'm gonna throw a
knight here they're gonna go Queen side
huh let's throw this pawn at him this
week in the dark squares I wanna get in
b4 okay the very strategic position okay
what dark square Bishop sixth mm now is
not the time to be thinking
Wow let's open up this side of the board
man they're Bruins they're signing up
something as h2 am I blind yeah
I think you have to do that
okay they still have some idea there and
now I'm in trouble I feel like I need to
pitch upon yolks and get my knight in
here scary
very very scary oh they're on I missed
that move first 15 seconds not cool man
not cool my night is still pin you do
realize that you probably want to get
out of a pin hmm not there
oh so scary so scary I can't I can't
think I can't think
you
man
got a queen
you
and I know how much time I have Drive
anytime
but time it's going blind all my eyes
are blurry my eyes are blurry 42 40 37
37 I can't read numbers killer calves
I'm two points back and he has fire
oh I feel like you know what I did
before I started the stream I charged my
mouse he's flying
I'm able to move really quick in this
tournament that doesn't mean I'm
performing any better oh you see this
happens just as I said that the slanted
board attacks
that's all it happened again again see
that it's not you're not your mind isn't
going crazy that's really happening that
happens so often I play it's distracting
man it needs to stop okay I don't know
what to do here let's post up in the
center we're gonna form a battery and
make make this night feel some pain um
move forward keep moving forward 93 and
there's so much for that okay we're
looking at f5 now have five is juicy how
are they doing about the have to move
the bishop to somewhere all right things
are looking good now we're gonna get a
piece and I hear I take first no they
resigned back to tournament fool really
52 he must've got two quick wins in
there huh 52 4437 31 Wow
two minutes 22 seconds 55 players in
this one he's playing game so I'm not
even gonna get paired up with the leader
minam Oh Ferrari again alright we're
gonna go with we're gonna we're gonna do
this again they're gonna go Queen side
but I'm gonna put a question to that c5
pawn sooner yeah I'm gonna allow h6
again so okay
but I'm targeting East six now aha so
there's some success here I have some
good checks and let's our x squared
Bishop Soph let's kick this oh I'm on
the Queen you went to g3 for a reason
not to just pretend that you're gonna
take the knight but to actually take the
knight ah if I lose this it'll be a sad
sad day please don't let it be a sad day
it's reciting now we're taking it upon
my my rook wants to play let's just
throw pieces over here hits a rook
defends e3 I've just taken that tricky
Knight
uh uh yeah let's just defend stuff I had
to go Queen side right only way forward
can I get a queen trade I could have
just taken the Queen forget about a
queen trade I like my Knights they're
really really good
we have a 10-second lead on the clock
yeah I should be able to get this one
let's take that pond and hunt down the
b-pawn next they resigned back
determined thirty seconds left
yeah that's gonna be it I don't think
I'm gonna get paired up again if I do it
won't matter for the tournament and it's
probably not enough time to get paired
17 seconds yeah it seems like it's going
to do it I'd be surprised if we got
paired again ten seconds no it's not
happening
wow he has a lot of games in we didn't
get paired once I got paired with
Ferrari what three or four times whoo
Wow 56 I'm a done 48 I got second 40
Ferrari and then 3128 24 as you see 55
players total Wow a really strong
turnout there I wasn't expecting that
from the initial group when the
tournament started so let's see page 2 3
4 5 & 6
all righty to the 55 of you that took
part in this good games all all right
there we go tough Shane 3 subscriber 19
months in a row thank you very much I
appreciate that Shane
you